for people who don't like the cold
winter is really miserable and here in
the Arctic it can be even more brutal
but the Arctic and where you live
worlds apart may be more connected than
you might think scientists are finding
that as temperatures in the Arctic Rise
changes here may be contributing to
extreme weather thousands of miles away
[Music]
temperatures are rising across the world
but the warming is strongest in the
Arctic here the warming is twice as fast
as the global average and that's causing
the ice to vanish in less than four
decades the Arctic has lost
three-quarters of its sea ice it covers
a third less of the ocean than it did
just 20 years ago that's drawn interest
from an international group of
researchers who have come north to
understand how the Arctic is rapidly
changing
[Music]
these changes create a nasty feedback
loop first the ice melts turning
reflective surface into a dark one that
absorbs solar energy warming up without
the ice more water evaporates
contributing to larger amounts of
greenhouse gases and all that extra heat
has had surprising effects the process
begins high in the atmosphere Earth's
air tends to move from the warm middle
of the planet to the poles because warm
air takes up more space it's taller so
gravity pulls it towards the Arctic
where the atmosphere is thinner and
shorter and this creates wind the earth
is spinning so instead a river of air
known as the jet stream is formed moving
west to east this is what the polar jet
stream looks like you can see the
patterns of its winds the jet stream
serves as a boundary between cold air
from the Arctic and warm air from the
tropics and its shape influences weather
patterns the Arctic atmosphere is
changing as the temperatures rise there
faster than further south there is less
gravitational pull on the air towards
the North Pole so the jet stream slows
down when it's curvy weather sticks
around longer causing bigger storms
droughts and cold spells some scientists
think that's supercharging extreme
weather across the world from the Helmer
Hansen I call atmospheric scientist
Jennifer Francis who explains how the
polar jet stream affected the u.s. this
past winter there was a huge northward
swing in the jet stream over the west
coast bringing lots of warm air to
Alaska it's been the hottest December on
record with most temperatures 2030
degrees above average and then the jet
stream took a big southward dive over
the Rockies and dipped way down into
Florida we haven't seen measurable snow
in Tallahassee own over 30 years it was
so cold that alligators got frozen into
a North Carolina swamp
that stubborn pattern persisted for
weeks and the extreme cold and heat got
worse and worse you can see why
meteorologists are calling it a bomb
cyclone Bom Bom Bom it's called Bombo
Genesis this is the Qura jet stream
pattern does it look familiar
it's the arctic air driving so far south
that it meets up with ocean air the Gulf
Stream is warm humid air while on the
research cruise the jet stream sent the
bomb cyclone up to the Arctic and we got
a wallop but then we enjoyed
temperatures that were almost pleasant
at times 20 degrees above average and
warmer than those in New York City
a week later the jet stream brought
extreme cold to Asia Russia and eastern
China were pounded with frigid cold
Tokyo had its coldest day in 48 years
while scientists scramble to understand
how the Arctic may be intensifying the
weather some prominent climate
researchers are skeptical scientists
can't definitively say whether anyone
weather event was caused by the warming
arctic conditions elsewhere or by random
chance but Francis and others think the
warming Arctic is loading the dice for
extreme weather we can confidently say
that some amount of the increase in
extreme weather that we're seeing is
because of climate change this is not a
question anymore one thing is for sure
extreme weather in North America is
occurring more often when the Arctic is
very warm very cold temperatures in the
eastern side of the United States are
likely climate scientists have given
this phenomenon a new name warm arctic
cold continents we tend to think of the
Arctic as a victim of climate change a
canary in a coalmine
but the vanishing ice may play a bigger
role on the global stage intensifying
extreme weather a world away
all right that is awesome
they're alive polar bear tracks
extending ominously close to the ship
[Music]
you